You've heard the talk about bringing cloud from the server room to the board room.
Well, cloud is no longer an IT buzzword,...
...it's a business reality.
It isn't just critical for big data and analytics,...
...it's critical to customer engagement initiatives like mobile and social.
We surveyed cloud decision makers and users from around the world, more than 800 of them,...
...to find out how organizations are really using cloud.
I'll give you a hint;...
...it's not just for operational efficiency in workflow optimization.
What we found is that forward-thinking companies across industries...
...are using cloud for strategic reinvention.
They're making better decisions and engaging with customers in smarter ways.
These pacesetters know it's about collaborating across the enterprise...
...and being responsive to the market and ultimately,...
...it's all about the customer experience.
In fact, pacesetters are 136 percent more likely to reinvent customer relationships using cloud.
It's time to get serious about your cloud strategy...
...because those who don't will be left behind.